donc le principe c'est le robot me suit
et porte la charge à ma place puisque
donc dans le robot je suis capable
d'installer ce que je veux capable de
porter des charges de plus de 40 kilos
ces robots collaboratifs sont utilisés
pour faciliter les déplacements dans les
usines des produits vendus notamment
dans le secteur automobile et
aéronautique
une fois qu'il a repéré son
environnement il devient autonome
c'est-à-dire qu'il âgées plus cette
télécommande et le robot il suffit sur
une carte sur un smartphone en fait du
programme est une destination et le
robot va est tout seul à cette
destination des équipements présentés
dans ce forum imaging mobility sur le
campus de l'estac a organisé par le pôle
de compétitivité movéo cette structure
veut faciliter les échanges entre les
grandes entreprises les pme et les
collectivités
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que pour
innover la puissance d'un grand groupe
donne des moyens mais l'agilité des
start up des pme
nous allons le démontrer c'est ça qui
crée souvent l'élan pour innover nous
aujourd'hui investir pour la mobilité
c'est investir j'irai dans l'avenir de
notre département parce que c'est ce qui
fera l'attractivité de notre territoire
parce que sans mobilité sans transport
un territoire n'est rien donc la
mobilité c'est ce qui va compter ce qui
va nous permettre aujourd'hui de prévoir
de prévoir notre territoire de demain de
prévoir aussi tout son développement
économique
les laboratoires représenté aussi lors
de cette journée des doctorants de
l'estaca ont présenté leurs travaux
énergie propre véhicule autonome qualité
de l'air des thématiques de recherche
on s'inspire de son tous les cas de ces
problématiques là pour donner des
projets ad
faire contribuer les étudiants estaca à
l'aboutissement de ce choc de ce genre
de projet une dizaine de projets de
recherche collaboratifs menée par des
étudiants de l'estaca ont reçu le label
movéo